vorher aber kurz zu einer Nachricht aus
Brüssel die manchen Gourmet vielleicht
den Magen umdrehen könnte jetzt dürfen
auch hausgrillen in Lebensmitteln
verwendet werden das erlaubt ab heute
ein EU-Gesetz klimaaktivisten jubeln
Insekten statt Rinder damit ließe sich
schließlich auch CO2 einsparen
getrocknet gefroren oder ist Pulver die
Grillen und auch Larven des Getreide
schimmelkäfers dürfen in vielen
Lebensmitteln verarbeitet werden im
Müsli in Keksen in Pizza in Suppen und
sogar Schokolade ja alles darf schon
bald mit Insekten angereichert werden
die Lebensmittelindustrie die freut sich
vermutlich über neue billige
streckenmittel wäre das nicht will der
muss genau auf die packen schauen machen
viele aber vielleicht auch nicht wir
haben hier mal eine bunte Mischung die
Sie vielleicht aus dem Dschungelcamp
kennen könnte man sagen ich will mal die
Frage hier auch in die Runde werfen
Carsten Stahl da ist viel Protein drin
wenn sie dazu greifen ist das etwas wo
sie sagen wir haben hier muss man sagen
das sind so kleine wo kann man aus dem
Dschungelcamp knusprig
also wenn ich jetzt ein paar von esse
beim Dschungelcamp geht's ja mit
Sternchen oder mit Geld also wenn ich
jetzt sage mal davon einiges Essen ich
darf von jetzt eine Essen machen wir das
so dass dann die Bild-Zeitung ein paar
tausend Euro an Kinderschutz macht dann
dann
eine kinderschutzbänder wenn ich das
jetzt hier hinein kippe das ganze Ding
denn die wenige genug
gleich ihr großes Thema hier aber jetzt
auch mal ernsthaft gesprochen
ist das eine Nahrung der Zukunft
dann verstehe ich auch warum das ein
oder andere eine oder andere nicht
richtig funktioniert aber
gar nichts und ich glaube nicht dass das
jetzt wirklich die Alternative sein
sollte die man uns auch zwingen sollte
sollte aber wirklich jeder entscheiden
dürfen und lesen dürfen das nicht
schmeckt das ist jetzt nicht schlimm ich
war bei der bundesessen
also ist ganz es war ja auch großes
Thema muss man sagen in der Wurst dort
wurden viele Lösungen für ein neues
Leben für die Zukunft gefunden gesucht
Herr Weinberg glauben Sie das neue
Speisepläne dieser Art neuer
Alternativen zu unserer Ernährung zu
suchen ein Weg in die Zukunft ist unsere
Welt zu einer besseren zu machen das
vorstellen also ich bin noch immer ein
steakesser und ähm
aber wenn sie mir das nicht übel nehmen
würde ich gerne verzichten wir können
auch anschließend gerne mal ins
Restaurant gehen was auch wichtig ist
oder fleischiges Essen nein also ich
muss ganz offen sagen ich wundere mich
über diese Beschlüsse weil ich kann die
Diskussion habe ich den Erinnerungen wie
das war um ging es umgehen manipuliertes
Essen und ähm sie sind in Amerika wird
das gemacht und das gehen meine
poliertes essen würde auch das
Hungerproblem in der Welt
lösen in Deutschland aber oder in Europa
gibt es nach wie vor große Widerstände
gegen gegen manipuliertes essen aber
solche Geschichten wie das scheint zu
funktionieren also das mal opinion
gekommen als Diplomat wurde ihnen schon
mal etwas angeboten bei dem sie dankend
ablehnen mussten würden Sie sagen die
Dinger sind jetzt kein Problem für mich
zeigt das hier noch mal es krabbelt
nichts mehr muss man sagen sondern also
erstens habe ich heute meinen Fastentag
aber zweitens wird man natürlich auch in
gewissen Situationen mal mit damit
konfrontiert und dann muss man
diplomatischen eins sagen können auch
und es kann nicht was würde ihnen da
angeboten wenn sie da was bestimmtes in
Erinnerung
nein sagen ja also diese diese Sachen
nicht bei Kaviar sag ich auch nein
aber nein
unabhängig davon ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir für unsere Ernährung
der Zukunft natürlich auch Alternativen
anschauen und dass wir versuchen
die unseren Fußabdruck im co2-bereich
also Kohlen Kohlendioxid dass wir den
reduzieren und Westen wenn das ein
Mittel ist das zu tun dann ist es
sicherlich nicht falsch ich muss ja
nicht jeder essen ja also ich ich
jedenfalls lehne dankend ab also ich
sehe schon hier der der meine Schlüssel
kriegt hier keine Mehrheit der Schnitte
auch sie sie schütteln im Kopf sie sind
ja auch auf der Wiese auf dem
Oktoberfest unterwegs da geht ein halbes
Hendl über den Tresen kommt der bald
glauben das Essen in der Zukunft ein
kleiner madenberger können sich das
vorstellen
ich habe eine sehr
katholische Erziehung genossen ohne das
ist das Wort flexitarier damals in der
60er Jahren gehabt waren wir dies wir
hatten drei fast Tage in der Woche
Montag Mittwoch Freitag fleischlos
einfach so religiösen Gründen ohne dass
das aufgezwungen wurde
frei Verbindlichkeit wir haben
mitgemacht und haben hinterfragt musste
sein musste und es war genau der
Gesundheit förderlich nicht jeden Tag
Fleisch zu essen ich denke bin bei allen
mit dabei wir müssen unsere Haltung
ändern wir müssen unsere
Lebensgewohnheiten ändern CO2-Ausstoß
und und und und aber es muss eine
gleitser Würmer sein dass sie die in
anderen Lebensmittel einschleichen
kümmern sowieso nicht verhindern also
wie in die Gummibärli
rindergele oder was da drin ist wird das
irgendwo drin sind und die schmeckt dann
immer raus dann egal
ich habe seit Jahrzehnten zu können
also was solls gehen manche kommen ja
gar nicht verhindern aber Leute Appell
bewusst zu leben wir werden darüber mit
Sicherheit was die Kinder betrifft sehr
intensiv darüber reden bewusst zu leben
und den anderen bewusste Lebensweise
Vorleben das ist das Ziel das Ende bei
dem Mann